our enthusiasts this event is for you
labs under the lights to benefit
speedway children's charities is taking
place next friday at las vegas motor
speedway here to tell us more is paul at
anderson with speedway children's
charities welcome thank you so much
thanks for letting me come back
constantly i'm so excited about this
event next friday how does this work how
does it all work yes so it's our laps
for charity under the lights so on uh
next friday august 26th from 8 pm to 11
pm people like yourself and your
colleagues here in the studio and the
whole community can bring out their cars
their trucks their motorcycles and they
get to drive their own vehicle around
the super speedway i mean we're talking
the super speedway where nascar races on
twice a year so you go 75 miles per hour
you follow a pace card there's about 12
at a time and for all the people saying
well i can go 75 on the i-15 well guess
what uh this way when you go up that
banking it's a little different
experience yes and i did it last year
it's such a thrill driving your car
around there yeah how is someone taking
pictures can we take photos ourselves
can we put gopros on our cars yes i
think everybody has a gopro these days
yes we do have a photographer so when
you get on pit road we will definitely
have your photo taken with your car and
then it'll be uploaded on our website to
get a free download after the event a
couple days later
you just have to be kids have to be six
and older to be in the back seat you
have to be 18 or older to drive but
what's so neat is that as long as you
have seat belts if you have say six seat
belts in your car you can have all six
people in there it's just one price so
it's 75 to go five laps which is amazing
that's a blast amazing and then it's a
hundred dollars for vips to go seven
laps and each lap you know it's las
vegas motor speedway so it is so much
fun and then the lights are on
and when it comes to the actual car
what's the role on that kid any car can
come out and do it what's the rule now
yes as long as it's street legal so if
you're able to get on the highway and
take it drive it down there you can get
on there exactly
exactly if it's street legal you got
your license you can do it like i said
it's a fun family event so if you pay a
hundred dollars to go seven laps you can
have you know as many people in the car
as there are seat belts and that's
what's great and all the money stays
local to go to speedway children's
charities and we help thousands and
thousands of kids in need every year so
this is a great way to end your summer
and i mean again this where else can you
do this in the world
well it is such a neat experience too
just being in the car and driving around
the speedway there and experience it
from the track and those turns the the
bank men's two stories high those turns
it's a pretty intense feeling right
around that track it is such a thrill
people have come back year after year
we're so grateful we do one in january
as well but this is under the lights
once a year under the speedway lights it
does not get any better i love it
paulette thank you so much for joining
us and i'll be there next friday night
it's gonna be a blast laps under the
lights is happening next friday august
26th starting at eight o'clock at las
vegas motor speedway to register just go
to speedwaycharities.org
beetle